welcome for our
hello if you
can really quickly tell me where you're
signing in from I'm located here in
Atlanta Georgia
Germany Kansas City Berlin a couple of
people from Berlin Spain New York Egypt
of Seattle UK India Oxford awesome a lot
of different places all over thanks for
the webinar yeah we're gonna have some
fun today hopefully everybody learned
something Saudi Arabia Bay Area will
welcome everybody from wherever you're
calling in welcome we appreciate you
taking time out of your day to join us
Irving Texas thank you all for joining
in for the call today all right let us
go ahead and get started so today we are
going to be talking about how to write
achievement statements and really in a
sense showing off a little bit so we're
gonna do some bragging a lot of the job
search is essentially you sharing and
showcasing some of your most impressive
skills as well as experiences so that's
what we're really gonna focus on today
and we're gonna do it in a way that is
ideal for you to kind of showcase this
on your resume as well as your LinkedIn
and anywhere else that it makes sense to
do that so my name is Brett Ellis I am a
career coach here with Udacity I have
worked most of my career with college
students as well as young professionals
and I tend to get a lot of career
changers that reach out to me as well
and I've worked in really a lot of
different industries so at this point I
am comfortable coaching a lot of
different people and I've been doing it
for over six years I specialize in
personal branding showcasing your impact
which was what we're gonna talk about
today through achievements and really
building your presence on LinkedIn it's
where I've really got my start doing
career coaching and have really
developed a name for myself using that
platform and just another thing to
mention I really love doing these
webinars and workshops so as I mentioned
before we're gonna have some fun today
and hopefully you all learn something
that you can take away and apply it's
who
job search as well as your careers
moving forward so today what we are
going to talk about is why you should
use achievement statement so first and
foremost why are you even here why do
you need to learn how to do this
secondly we're going to have you all
brainstorm some of your own achievement
so you're gonna get some things you're
gonna take some time to reflect and
really work through some of your own
specific experiences we're going to use
they star slash car framework for
planning achievement so if you've been
to any of our interview workshops this
will be familiar to you and if you plan
on attending any of our workshops in the
future this will be some good review for
you as well the next thing we're gonna
do is talk about how to actually write
your achievement statement so a lot of
people simply just list them or they
don't know how to put it on paper to
where it makes sense and where it's
concise so we're gonna talk about that
as well so that you can have a resume
full of achievement statements that's
not too bulky and too long and then the
next thing that we're gonna do is we're
gonna actually do some practice I'm
gonna have you all share with each other
and hopefully we can do some on-the-spot
feedback because if you take advantage
of this webinar correctly you may
actually be able to copy and paste some
of the things that you've worked on to
actually put into your resume or
LinkedIn and then lastly we're gonna
talk about some additional benefits of
having an achievement based style we'll
open it up for some Q&A and then just
some closing statements so let's go
ahead and jump right in so first we'd
like to know from you all and you can
just type in the chat have you ever
written achievement statements or have
you do you have any achievement
statements on your resume or on your
LinkedIn have you listed any
achievements that you have
I'm gonna pull up this chat as well okay
okay I missed that h-town hold it down
hey Texas okay so no no yes no no no no
no tried to okay well we're gonna do
that not sure how should it look we'll
go through that Wesley has go ahead
Wesley just two to three lines in the
resume okay not as an achievement show
and not tell achievements include
metrics yep Christopher you sounds like
you've got an idea yes a couple of lines
okay so it sounds like for the most part
that most people haven't had much
experience doing this and the people who
have maybe a couple of times and some
people sound like they may have a good
understanding of what we're gonna talk
about but hopefully you have a better
everybody has a better understanding of
what we're trying to accomplish today
after we go through a couple of
strategies as well as examples so lots
of nose glad I'm glad they're here as
well so we're gonna get right into it
and hopefully we'll have a lot of time
for you out of practice
okay so first I mentioned we were gonna
talk about why you should use
achievement statements and so I have a
top eight list so obviously this is just
the first four but we're gonna go
through these right now and I'll kind of
give some context for what I mean by
these so number one it sets you apart
from everybody else with similar
experience so let's say for example you
are a teacher and you're competing for a
position that may be a step above a
teacher chances are you'll be competing
with a lot of different teachers who
have similar experience from yourself
and if you just go the traditional route
of writing resumes where you list out
your roles and responsibilities it's
going to look something like oversee a
classroom of this many students manage
classroom behavior create lesson plans
those types of things and it's really
hard for you to stand out amongst a huge
pool of candidates who have similar
experiences so when you do achievements
it's really hard to replicate because
these are coming directly from your own
individual contributions number two it
gives you a chance to show
problem-solving abilities through actual
examples so it at the end of the day
every job opening is an is a chance to
solve a problem so if an employer posts
a job they need somebody to fill that
gap so they have a problem that needs to
be solved or they need somebody to come
in and achieve some of the goals that
the company has so if you're just purely
listing out your roles and
responsibilities it may showcase that
you have done it before but this really
gives you a chance to show that you've
solved problems and that you've solved
problems that they need to be solved so
it can give them a really good idea of
how you can achieve the goals that
they're looking to accomplish as well
number three it's actually expected from
some employers and recruiters now so if
your resume is just kind of one of those
regurgitating job descriptions where
you're listing out all of your roles and
responsibilities those aren't seen as
attractive as an achievement based
resume or a resume that includes a lot
of problem-solving ability as well as
your individual contributions to a
company so some of them expect it now
even outside of the other benefits that
it provides so it can be really helpful
for you to learn this so if you are
tuned in today good for you
it's gonna be very helpful for you and
your job search in the number-four it
helps you feel like you are represented
on your resume and not just your
experience so a lot of people say oh I
can interview I'm good with an interview
I just have a hard time showcasing
myself on paper and the reason for that
is because most people are not
represented on their resume it's their
jobs because they're simply listing out
their job descriptions in their own
words so when you go with the
achievement based format it allows you
to really showcase things that you have
specifically done and things that you've
contributed to the department or the
organization and then lastly it just
kind of really is a confidence booster
when you know that you are represented
and you're represented in a good way on
your resume so number five it helps you
to prepare stories in advance for your
interview so if you have been to any of
our interview workshops if you have if
you plan on attending any of our
interview workshops this will be really
helpful for you because if you have
several achievements listed on your
resume or on your LinkedIn and already
have them planned out it can be really
helpful when you're asked a specific
question in our interview especially
with those behavior based questions
where they ask you to provide a specific
situation or questions that sound like
tell me about a time when you had to
create a project from start to finish or
lead an event with little resources
those types of questions where they're
asking for one specific instance this
can really help you because you have a
lot of stories already prepared when you
plan them out this way
number six reading achievements are just
more exciting so if you are an employer
and you're trying to hire somebody let's
say you're hiring somebody for a social
media manager position compare these two
runs department social media page versus
increase social media following by a
hundred and fifty percent by creating
engaging online content and hosting
Instagram contests obviously this one's
a little bit more exciting because it
includes some results and it also
provides specific numbers to the success
that you
versus just listing that you've done it
it can be really helpful to do that and
then seven it shows that you do your job
well so if you're just kind of listing
out the things that you do nothing about
that showcases whether or not you are
actually good at your job and so
highlighting your achievements can
sometimes show that not only are you
good at your job it can show that you've
gone above and beyond your roles and
responsibilities and so this is a really
good way to showcase that you're
actually good at your job and can really
make you stand out amongst people who
just kind of list out the roles and
responsibilities and then lastly it
shows that you pay attention to what
employers want to see so as I mentioned
previously it is expected but for a lot
of different employers it can be helpful
to have the knowledge and the skills in
your industry but it can also be helpful
to showcase to employers that you know
how to job search that you know the
trends that are going on in job
searching as well as in resume writing
and interviews regardless of the content
and the skills that you have it can be
really helpful to showcase to them that
you stay on trend with what employers
are looking for and I there's a quote
that I read recently that said it's it's
not who's the best for the job that gets
the job it's the person who's the best
job seeker who gets the job and so
sometimes just knowing how to do this
process correctly can help you beat out
people who are even more so qualified
than you might be so those are my top
eight reasons why you should have
achievement statements and hopefully
that will encourage you and motivate you
to take kind of this next part seriously
so we can really focus on helping you
all to develop some of those for
yourself do we have any questions so far
and take a brief look at the chat
okay
okay sounds like these are a little bit
related to other things so we're gonna
talk now about brainstorming some
achievements so as you're thinking about
it a lot of times I'll hear students say
well I can't think of anything I just do
my job
or I don't my job doesn't allow me to do
anything that is achievement worthy or
they just don't have a lot of confidence
in the work that they've produced and so
here are a couple of questions to get
you thinking so you can start to
brainstorm the achievements that you
actually do have so one is if you're
involved at all in sales any type of
sales which is you know most people who
work for our business this can be
helpful for you to have percentages or
dollar amounts and you can give a very
specific quantifiable achievement a lot
of people struggle with putting numbers
to their achievements and for people who
work in sales or anything related to
sales this can be really helpful to
consider another thing is did you kind
of generate new business or increase
your client base maybe this was through
marketing efforts so if you have any any
involvement in that increasing the
client base and increasing awareness
about the products or the service is
that the business offers think about
those as well did you design or
Institute any new system or process so
maybe there was something that you came
in and noticed that could possibly be
better if you just tweaked it a little
bit or if you added something that
you've implemented in the past to make
it better I think for a lot of Udacity
students with just with a lot of the
nanodegree programs this one might be
pretty popular for you all considering
the fact that a lot of you are really
good at processes and improving those
for the different businesses that you or
organizations that you're working for
another thing is outside of making money
have you helped save money this can be
really appealing to employers as well so
you can really showcase that the things
that you're doing have either saved time
increased efficiency or just outright
saved money by finding better suppliers
or vendors or anything like that to
where you may have saved money or helped
a project come in
and then another one is did you
introduce any new or more effective
systems processes techniques anything
like that and so these are literally
just a couple of questions this is by no
means an exhaustive or comprehensive
list of the different questions that you
can use to start thinking of the
different achievements that you've had
and so for those of you who may not have
a lot of access to data which is where a
lot of these questions are gonna come in
you have to kind of sometimes take
yourself out of your current situation
and look at yourself in the organization
and see what impacts are you having even
somebody as you know as simple as like a
front desk assistant or somebody who
literally just answers phone calls that
person has achievements that they can
think of and so you have to kind of
sometimes think outside of the box and
remove yourself from this thought that
it has to be this grand scale major
thing that you accomplished it may just
be the fact that you increase the
efficiency or you reduce your
supervisors workload or you eliminated
the amount of incoming calls or reduce
the amount of incoming calls those types
of things so you you have to one give
yourself a little bit more credit if
this is hard but honestly another thing
that you might need to consider it is
finding a role or finding opportunities
in your role to where you can really
start to brainstorm some of these things
Rachele do we have any questions that
need to be addressed so far
let me see doing achievements for okay
more about the slides okay
LinkedIn cool alright so moving forward
I want you all to type in the chat you
don't have to write this out as if you
would put it on your resume but I want
to hear some of the things that you all
would consider some achievements that
you have this can either be in your
current role this can be in a previous
role or a recent role it may even be a
project that you completed for your
nanodegree that you're really proud of
that you think might be appealing to
employers so I'd love for you all to
kind of type in what you feel like one
of your recent achievements is create an
online course evaluation system at work
that's awesome
I'm sure that's really good for them
improving process is moving forward
somebody asks does giving achievements
for an old job work for someone looking
for a career change so that's a really
good question so ultimately it's ideal
for your achievements to be related to
the jobs that you want to do but at the
end of the day if your achievement is
not as related but it's still something
that you'd like to showcase it can be
helpful to do that just so you showcase
to them that you have done your job well
or that you have gone a little above and
beyond
somebody said built and designed new
machine that increased production of the
facility that's awesome that's
definitely gonna be something that you
can use for the activity we have coming
up Christopher said improve system
performance by 20% and reduced total
response time by 10% for a multi-core
platform within six weeks Chris I'm
gonna hand this over to you so you can
take over the rest of the webinar no I'm
kidding but that's really good I have a
little bit of advice for you on just
building that just making a little bit
better but great one I'm creating a
blackjack game for Android and uploaded
to the Google Play Store that's really
cool quit my previous job and start a
startup okay
we'll want to build on that a little bit
more how do we list a project done as a
group so for something like that you'll
want to focus specifically on what your
individual contributions were but you
can still kind of utilize that overall
result and then focus specifically on
what you did but we'll get into that a
little bit more further on in the
workshop I'm conducting an SEO audit and
running Facebook Ads
okay that's more so the actions I would
encourage you to think about what
happened as a result of that I graduated
and don't have any work experience can I
write about competitions competitions
about what manage development of
information system for public sector
organization okay that's an once again
that's more of an action you'll want to
talk about what is what what happened as
a result of that new way to solve a
problem on the data aisle in a lot the
data analysis that's a good one
self-employed that's doing a bit of
everything outside of this I also run my
own business and I have a ton of
achievements that I can share so if even
if you work for yourself make sure that
you're tracking your progress as well as
keeping data for the work that you do
because you can still highlighted Eve
menteur self-employment okay there's a
lot okay not too many left create an
easy to follow documentation that's a
good one
saved hundreds okay awesome that one's
good
is that Leah Leah you your your step
ahead good job research design implement
solution architecture gotcha
I don't know what a lot of those words
mean but they probably sound good to
employers I'll help you walk through
what that might look like in terms of
really building that out soon found it
created and done art project for
children okay cool use deep learning to
create all right
okay sounds good so very good it sounds
like most of you have some ideas of what
you would consider your achievements
some of them were moreso actions but we
can talk about what what the result was
um because of your actions and that will
be ultimately kind of where your your
achievements lie but thank you all for
sharing all those I'm highly impressed
if you if you don't have these things on
your resume that's a missed opportunity
so it's a good thing that you showed up
for today's workshop because a lot of
the things that you've listed are very
very impressive and are also going to be
very impressive for employers to be
reviewing throughout your job search
documents see one more question do
recruiters assume that achievements are
individual achievements and not those of
a team so it does depend on how you word
it but for the most part if I was
working on a team I think that the
result is ultimately gonna be the same
for all of us but when I start to
elaborate more on that achievement I'm
gonna talk more specifically on my
individual contributions and so I I
wouldn't assume that that a recruiter is
going to make those connections but just
the way that you write it and if you
focus on specifically what you did it's
more so about how you can explain to
them if you're asked about it so if they
do ask you a question in an interview
about a specific achievement that you
listed you can be able to showcase that
and say that you know these were my
individual contributions that led to
this group result okay so let's move on
and if you have any other questions as
we continue going hopefully some of the
things that I'll talk about will
eliminate some of the questions you
might have right now
so as I mentioned before we use a very
similar strategy here at Udacity for
interviewing so if you have attended one
of those workshops or planned to this is
gonna be something that is gonna
continue to keep coming up so you might
as well learn it now
and really drill it into your brain this
this star strategy or car strategy
either way they're the same thing so
star is an acronym it stands for
situation task action z' and results or
if you go the car route it's challenge
actions and results and so that
situation and task is also kind of
sometimes the challenge so you want to
think of the challenge as a problem you
had to resolve or something that an
issue that you faced that you really
needed to to to tackle and so an
important thing to consider here is that
it might not always need to be mentioned
and it might be assumed so a good
example of that might be let's say for
example you won
developer of the month at your company
there wasn't really a challenge that
needed to be solved it was just more so
that you did really well at your job or
that you went above and beyond so
sometimes it's not always about an issue
that needed to be solved sometimes it
was just about an achievement that you
accomplished because of the work that
you are doing so it's not always going
to be explicitly stated and when we
start to write out your achievement
statements sometimes you'll notice that
the situation or task is not present
anyways because it can sometimes be
assumed or inferred and then your
actions what specific actions did you
take so a couple of the questions before
hand were about you know working in
groups so you don't necessarily want to
include achievement statements on your
resume when you include actions that you
didn't really have a part in doing you
want to focus more specifically on the
specific actions that you had and then
the results can be more group related or
what the overall result was and then so
lastly results as you've heard is going
to be a common term that we continue to
use throughout this webinar because this
is ultimately what employers are looking
for this is what employers look for even
if you're entrepreneur or self employed
your clients are gonna want to see
results they're gonna gonna they're
gonna want to see work and how you've
helped whoever you've been working
with it's the same thing with employers
so regardless of whether or not you're
job searching or looking for
self-employment it's gonna be really
helpful for you to focus on the results
because that's ultimately what they're
looking for because once again they have
an issue that needs to be solved and
they're looking for somebody potentially
you who can solve that problem for them
and if you're able to showcase that
you've already done it and already done
it well it helps you stand out from
everybody else who's applying so we have
some time we want you all to practice so
this activity we want you to think of an
achievement so maybe one that you listed
before think of an achievement from a
recent job or a project or something
that you completed through your Udacity
nano degree it will probably be more
beneficial if you focus more so on work
experience but if you are a career
changer in your past experience isn't
super related to what you're trying to
do you can focus on something that you
did within your nano degree program and
I want you to take some time and I want
you to write it out and I want you to
write it out very similar to how I have
here on the right where the example so
you can do a challenge an action and a
result and you can just plan it out that
way this is not you writing this for
your resume just yet we're still
brainstorming the different things that
you've done and really reflecting on
some of your experiences start
highlighting some of those achievements
so take some time now I'd love for you
to really brainstorm and work through
some of these because as you start to
practice I'll have you guys share again
and then provide some on-the-spot
feedback so you can actually have a
fully written achievement statement that
you can put on your resume
so yes take some time now grab a piece
of paper or even put it in your phone
and jot down some of the the different
things that you would like to include
for your achievement statement so think
of one specific situation one specific
achievement that could be really helpful
for you especially in landing the next
role that you want or your desired
future role
how many words should it have don't
worry about that just yet
just worry about getting it out out of
your head and onto paper or in your
phone and some notes just brainstorm it
out right now you shouldn't worry about
how many words right now
you
could we use the results of our project
achievements outside of our project
description I think you can if it's
written well enough and it's not too
redundant then yeah how can developers
list results without being held
accountable for the products concept
which is not the I am not extremely
familiar with what you're asking this
may be a more technical question that
may be better suited for your nano
degree mentor yeah I'm not sure I'm not
sure what you're asking if you can
simplify it for me I may be able to help
you so before you start sharing
the chat just kind of shot these things
down outside or put it put it in your
phone or maybe in on your computer and a
word document something like that so
where you can get it down
okay that's I understand that okay so
you're saying if you develop a great app
but the startup failed so you're saying
can you still list the results I think I
think you can I think I would focus more
specifically on what your app I guess
what your what your app achieved outside
of like success in the business so give
me a little bit more context on what the
app was used for and you can jump on the
chat if you'd like you don't have to
type it out
and if you finished one go ahead and
work on another one if you can I'm gonna
give a couple more minutes for those of
you who are still working on it
once you're finished with at least one
let me know in the chat
that's good Raul that's good for those
of you who are still trying to figure it
out this is a good example to look at
just brainstorming it out not
necessarily trying to write an official
statement just yet
but getting it out of your head and onto
paper on some notes or somewhere website
portfolio wherever you think you'll help
you stand out applying for a job so
we're not gonna have time to check out
your your portfolio but it's definitely
helpful one of the things that I've done
is actually written out my achievement
statements on my resume and included
hyperlinks on there that show that link
to work samples so for example I have
one that says that I did a workshop like
the workshop led to increase proficiency
and resume writing or something like
that and then you can actually click on
where I have the workshop listed and it
will take you to all of that data show
it showcases what students knew before
and what students knew after and you can
see the percentage increase there so
I've taken it up a notch that's a really
good point to mention so if you do have
an online portfolio or even a PDF resume
that can be helpful for you to link
directly to the work sample as well
okay so
and I want to get an idea of how many
people is anybody still working or still
brainstorming trying to figure this out
anybody struggling having any questions
this should just be you getting it out
of your head and onto paper or on to a
Notes app done okay anybody still
working gotten one written down still
trying to frame okay
Malan hopefully we can help you we're
gonna do some some breakout sessions for
you all to share but if you're if you
have any specific questions let me know
so know if you guys please we're not
we're not going to be able to review
anybody specific portfolios here on this
webinar we're focused more so on just
the writing achievement statements so it
sounds like most people have kind of
gotten a chance to okay good everybody's
worked out anybody else still struggling
Milan do you have any specific questions
or you can wait until we do the breakout
I'll do my best to join your group first
hopefully that'll help okay so we're
gonna go ahead and move forward if you
don't have it down 100 percent that's
totally okay most of the people that I
work with you know aren't grasping this
fully fully until they get a chance to
really practice and work more than one
out so we're gonna go ahead and kind of
recap this strategy in a way that you
can actually start to write them out so
when it comes to your achievement
statements that last step I really just
wanted you to focus on getting it out of
your head and start to brainstorm
because this is what you'll want to do
anytime you start to think of your
achievements and so one of the best ways
to do it is to really flip the story
completely so this is like journalism
101 any time you open a newspaper or
read the news it's always the results
first so it might say millions of
dollars raised or hundreds of students
graduate or a thousand sick after
outbreak something like that it always
leads with the results because that just
works into human psychology and getting
them more excited about reading so one
of the best ways to do it is to lead
with your results and then follow up
with your actions so I wanted to share
an example so let's say we use this
workshop as an example what I might have
done from the previous one where I
listed out that students were having
issues doing this I created the workshop
and reached out to the marketing team
and then you know the results hopefully
100 students but so you flip it for for
that writing and it says improved 100
plus students resume writing ability by
creating a writing achievement
statements webinar and collaborating
with the marketing team to promote
student to promote to students so you're
highlighting that result and you're
following it up with your specific
actions and so that's a really good way
to write out your achievement statements
to where it touches on that problem that
you solved as well as have it in a
condensed format so your resume it's not
paragraphs of different things and so
it's a way to make it really brief and
to the point but you're still getting
that message across
so here's another example that might be
more familiar to some of you increased
operating from three point five to four
stars by inspecting error reports and
fixing a bug that caused the app to
crash when some users uploaded pictures
so from that one you can definitely see
what the challenge was and you can also
see what the actions were in terms of
expecting the air inspecting the error
reports and fixing a bug and then the
results are right there where it says
that you increase the operating so those
are two examples of you taking that kind
of brainstorm piece and then condensing
it to a more standard format that's
gonna be shorter and more to the point
so now we are going to break you up into
some breakout rooms and we would love
for you all to practice actually writing
out what you would put on a resume or on
a LinkedIn statement so take what you
did in the challenge action result
brainstorming where you're just listing
all those things out and try to lead
with the results and follow up with your
actions sometimes it'll make sense for
the challenge to be there sometimes it
won't but you really want to make sure
that the results and the actions are
there so that you can showcase your
ability to solve problems as well as the
process that was included so take some
time to do that if you struggled in the
first section hopefully we'll have some
time to really help you in terms of
highlighting those achievements that you
can actually put on your resume as well
as your LinkedIn and anywhere else that
it makes sense to do that
so yeah it's time to brag a little bit
you ought to show off show us what
you've been working on help us
understand that another good way to
think about it is you know these are
these are problems that you could
potentially solve for an employer so we
are going to break you up into groups so
hold off right now on putting it in the
chat and if you have put it in the chat
put it in there again when you get
broken up into the different rooms
buddy who didn't get a chance to share
in the group setting I want for someone
to share in the Indus group now one of
their achievements if you didn't get a
chance to share in your group session or
if I wasn't able to make it to your
breakout group to see your post try to
post it there now everybody's back in
the session now so let's see okay
built an app that got okay we'll figure
that out later right
in the first days I designed the app as
marketing and sales tool users can place
and configure each product in original
size in their environment so that's good
it has all of the pieces there I would
just word it a little bit differently to
where it flows is kind of like one
statement and not three different
sentences it's right now you have all
the pieces but just kind of wording it
to make it flow a little better and make
it easily read made representative
assembly of 25 million people fully
automated and now ended now a paperless
environment or all business processes
are performed using contemporary ICT
okay
good
so it seems like you guys have have the
gists to have kind of a better
understanding let me go ahead and pull
the slides back up yeah it sounds like
everybody has a good understanding of at
least the process it sounds like a lot
of people are better off than they were
before it is ultimately gonna take some
practice like I said we have you know
almost 40 people in here and we're only
practicing really one example so this is
something that you're really gonna want
to try and do a little bit more of and
so it'll take practice we will be able
to send this well we will have a link
once the event is done recorded so if
you want to go back and listen to it
again and see some of the slides where
we have those examples of good examples
of achievement statements that may be
helpful for you in terms of creating
those achievement statements so it does
just take some practice sometimes and
this will really help you to create a
really powerful resume if you have those
achievements listed for each one of the
positions that you have as well as some
of the projects that you've completed if
you don't have a lot of experience or a
lot of direct experience so now I want
to know from the group share in the chat
what is like one takeaway what is one
thing that you learned or if you have
any specific questions from this session
that I can answer and please make sure
the questions are related to this make
sure they're related to writing
achievement statements so that we can
really help everybody in the group I
want to try to avoid any very very
specific questions to your career path
so that we can help as many people in
the room as possible any specific
takeaways or questions that anybody has
from this session
you
see how can someone with less work
experience showcase their skills that's
a good question it is very very
difficult at the end of the day most
employers are going to want to see
experience they're going to want to see
results and so if you don't have a lot
of experience my best piece of advice is
to really work to highlight some of your
projects and then just do your best to
start to gain some experience and I know
that's kind of hard to do but a couple
of ways to do that are to volunteer
maybe do some freelance work find ways
to do that and one of the things that I
do specifically is any time I'm in a
role I spend about a month well I spent
about like an hour a month I usually put
it on my calendar I block it off to
reflect on my achievements and so if
you're going through and you're saying
okay this is the second month in a row
where I don't have anything to talk
about that's a good opportunity for you
to start brainstorming like in my
current role or if I don't have a
current role what can I be doing outside
of this to start developing achievement
statements that are related to the
career path that I want to pursue and
the different jobs that I'm looking at
so as you're preparing for the next step
in your career start to look at those
job descriptions and see what they're
asking for because then you can get an
idea of how you can start planning out
achievements and once again you don't
have to be working for a company or an
organization to have them you can create
those experiences for yourself let's see
what else all right Alex learned how to
flip the story that's important just for
readability how long should the ideal
achievement be for example less than 50
40 words don't worry too much about the
word count it's gonna make more sense to
think about it in terms of how it
actually looks on your resume so I would
say probably somewhere between like
one two four lines anything beyond
that's gonna be very bulky and and not
gonna be something that employers really
want to spend time reading so you want
to make it concise and get to the point
so most of the ones that I write and
help people write are right around to
two full lines you don't want to go to
two full lines and have like one word
that takes up that whole line and there
you're just wasting space so I recommend
trying to condense that or make it
another full line that way it looks it
looks a little bit better and you're
utilizing your resume space more
effectively so don't worry too much
about the word count worry moreso about
how it reads and how it looks on paper
so you'll have to actually work on
typing those out for to get a better
idea how make it she how to make
achievement statements as concise as
possible without missing important
details that's a really hard thing to
balance so that's a really good question
because that's one of the things that
most people struggle with um you want to
get the point across but you don't have
to go into so much detail one way that I
would recommend doing it is write it out
to where it's easily understandable for
somebody who was not there so if you can
take a look at somebody's achievement
statement and understand what happened
that's a good achievement statement if
you read it and you have questions where
you're saying okay well you said that
you did this but you're not giving me
enough information to understand what
that actually looks like then you may
need to provide a little bit more detail
so I use that kind of as best practice
just make sure that somebody who's
reading it could understand it without
actually having to be there or do the
work that you did presenting my
achievement can make other people assess
me better that's a good takeaway it
definitely helps you stand out from
other people how many achievements
should I put if so it I have so many
different achievements in different
fields should I keep them all so that's
a good problem to have first and
foremost congrats on having a whole lot
of achievements but I would say kind of
think about your achievements in terms
of like what are your most recent in
your most relevant position so if your
current role if you've been there for a
couple of months or at least a year you
should have a couple of things to talk
about but I would highly recommend that
you put more achievements for the
experiences and the jobs that are going
to be more impressive to a job
candidates so even if you took a break
let's say you want to go for a data
analyst job and your current role is a
data analyst you should have more
achievements there then maybe your
previous position and where I don't know
maybe you were working in something like
an internship that would still be good
to include some but you're gonna want to
put more emphasis on the more important
ones and then ultimately your
achievement should be somewhat closely
related to the role that you're applying
for so there's not really a certain
number that I can give you it's just
gonna be a matter of what makes sense
for the jobs that you're applying for
should we write the achievements in a
separate page I wouldn't I would put
them right there within your work
experience so don't even create a
separate section just list it right
under your jobs this is great thank you
of course the flip is new is it better
to quantify results in absolutes or an
increase percentages so it depends it
depends on how it reads sometimes I do
one sometimes I do the other sometimes I
do both so as it reads make sure that it
just it's it's very easily readable and
that it makes the most sense because
sometimes it might be a 2% increase but
that maybe hundreds of you know whatever
the data that you're dealing with so
sometimes it's about playing into the
psychology of the person reviewing it
and increasing something by a hundred
users is gonna sound a lot more
impressive than saying that you increase
it by two percent so that's just
something to keep in mind as well
question where should I put the
achievement statement good question once
again I would put it right there where
you're listing your job on the resume
okay flipping it can you please explain
the flipping the story so really
flipping the story is just for the first
part was for you to plan it out so you
do the challenge the action the result
that's just you kind of getting your
thoughts out of your head onto paper and
then would you write it out on the
resume you flip it so the results are
first that's just to help people get
more excited about wanting to read it if
I intend to use my projects as
achievements since I'm a career changer
do you mean that my project descriptions
also be um they can be they can be if
you if you want to find a way to list
your projects as achievements because
there is going to be an end result
that's the whole idea of the project
okay thank
you all for all of those questions I
really appreciate you all attending we
are unfortunately out of time if this
was helpful please stay tuned for our
future webinars and workshops if you
want to we do have several coming up you
can take a look at our events calendar
this this learning here will be really
applicable to some of our interview
workshops as well if you're not
comfortable with this just yet
continue working on it continue
attending our webinars and our workshops
to just get better if you're not fully
comfortable totally okay just keep
working on practicing yes if you didn't
have if your questions weren't answered
please reach out on slack or student
we'll do our best to answer those
you all are very welcome thank you all
for attending
you